we've got some breaking news this
morning a new secret Nazi dog whistle
has just dropped in recent years the
list of officially approved secret Nazi
dog whistles has grown to include
cartoon frogs the okay gesture and milk
and now a new one has dropped
and that new one is the time frame of
six months since FDR's time in office
the legislative metric in the United
States has been a hundred days not six
months this is a racist code whistle to
every white supremacist in the country
because it's how long it took out off
Hitler to take Weimar Germany to a
complete and total dictatorship that
included by the way the military
swearing an oath of Allegiance not to
the nation but to the fuhrer and the
military was the institution amongst
many in Germany that were the last
holdouts to this
but once he was in power they were the
first to submit
and what Donald Trump is signaling to
the officer Corps of the American
Military you get in line behind me the
leader not the idea not the Constitution
or I'm coming for you too this is an
epically dangerous moment
epically Steve Schmidt hates the time
frame of six months to a year presumably
because as a member of the Lincoln
project he prefers ages closer to 14
years maybe 15 years but whatever the
case against six months to a year it's
difficult to see how this relates to the
Nazis it is not I'm sorry to say a
particularly credible accusation
particularly because the same sort of
people who accuse anyone to their right
of being a Nazi for the flimsiest of
reasons just a few days ago exalted an
actual Nazi from the Waffen SS because
they thought it might help Ukraine or
something
it is not consistent
it doesn't make any sense of course but
it doesn't have to
give these people six months to a year
and they will come up with an entirely
new set of reasons to call you a Nazi
and try to push you out of society I'm
Michael knowlesis the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get
great meat at a secure price and 25
bucks off at your order with code
Knowles kwles go to goodrancis.com use
code Knowles today Britney Spears is
Dancing with knives we will get to that
very important story in just one moment
first though
I cannot stop laughing about the Ukraine
Nazi story I can't with Trudeau and
zelinski and the whole MPS and they're
just applauding and the guy apparently
surfed with evoffin SS Politico is
trying to water this down Politico has
changed the story to Nazi linked veteran
received Ovation during zelinski's
Canada visit
Nazi linked Nazi he fought with the
Nazis it's not it's not like his cousins
Grandma's brother's friend had a
pamphlet that was given to him by some
Nazi guy he fought with the Nazis doing
Nazi things
and they say no no he's just sort of
Nazi linked you know you you are
literally a Nazi for not
but the literal Nazi is only Nazi linked
according to Politico
it's actually slightly more complicated
than this
not in the way Politico is pretending
not in the way the libs are pretending
but it's more complicated because you
have lots of conquered territories
during the war you've got lots of
different groups who are making
different sort of arrangements with uh
political Powers some of which are
happier than others and so actually this
unit that this guy was in was not
totally bought into all of the Nazi
stuff and they they were fighting
exclusively against the Bolsheviks but
you know he's a literal Nazi guys come
on come on man come on man speaking of
narratives I'm in Washington DC right
now I had a speech last night at
Georgetown you can catch that speech at
the Y A F YouTube channel it was on
whether or not Biden is a more evil
ruler than Putin or she also on the
political Theology of dinoza Cortez but
largely about how Biden is a big jerk so
you can go watch that speech and in DC
just down the road from where I am the
Washington National Cathedral has
replaced its stained glass with BLM type
propaganda
uh the cathedral has unveiled a set of
four new stained glass windows just this
past Saturday dedicated to the theme of
racial Justice
and those installations were to replace
the previous windows which
depicted Stonewall Jackson which
depicted Robert E Lee which depicted
some of the great figures of the South
and of the reconciliation that took
place after the Civil War my first
thought is
episcopalians are going to Episcopalian
you know this is what they do
it's sad to say I have listened some of
my very best friends in Episcopalian
okay but
there's that good old line variously
attributed to Dean Inge or Fulton Sheen
which is that if you wed the spirit of
the age you'll find yourself a widow in
the next and the episcopalians gotta
love them but they have particularly
fallen into this trap so now
an Episcopalian service a Episcopalian
public life is just a series of
political fads it's really not all that
different from just watching a liberal
newscast and so it's no surprise that
they would get rid of these stained
glass windows and replace them with the
new fashions of whatever the vision of
racial Justice is today but don't forget
it's not like they were replacing
stained glass windows of the evangelists
stained glass windows of the Saints
they were replacing stabilized Windows
of Stonewall Jackson and Robert E Lee
why why were those even the stained
glass windows well because
after the Civil War
those windows were put up as a sign of
coming back together this war that
almost ripped the country completely in
in half it was it was a gracious gesture
for the conquered people the conquered
people being in the South and this is
what's so strange about this new moment
and this little symbol in the churches
the the old windows honored the Concord
South the new windows honor the
conquerors I'm not I don't mean racial
conquerors I mean ideological conquerors
the old windows look the north won the
War the Union won the war and yet they
paid a little bit of homage to the South
the new windows pay homage to
progressivism the progressive view of
History the past was really bad the
future is going to be really good the
president is always a crisis
white people bad black people good old
people bad young people good
the the new windows honor the the
ideological conquerors because
progressivism has has conquered the
country that is the uh ideology that
animates the whole country now
and so you would think if they wanted to
keep this in line with the old windows
they would maybe pay some homage to the
conservatives or to the normal people or
to maybe Christians wouldn't that be
nice in our National Cathedral if they
had the windows honoring Saints and
honoring uh evangelists and honoring
figures from the Bible but no that's not
how it works
the days of malice toward none and
charity for all the days of extending an
olive branch to the Concord
that's over that the progressive see no
role for that they see no role for Grace
because the progressives have sold out
the religion that animated our entire
civilization Christianity they've
replaced it with political stained glass
windows one thing that I really don't
like when I'm on the road I have a good
time when I'm on the road I like meeting
the students I like giving the speeches
I like the Q a one thing I don't like
them is that I don't get to eat
delicious good ranchers right now go to
goodranchors.com use code Knowles this
is the thing that I I hate about being
on the road
the one thing is I don't get to eat my
delicious good ranchers because sweet
little Elise has got it at home I love
good ranchers it is the absolute best
meat out there
it comes straight to your door you can
pick what you want to be for the pork or
the chicken or the fish now it's just so
freaking good it's 100 American you also
can get uh 500 in savings if you order
right now they'll also lock in your
price for two years which is completely
insane uh no other company guarantees
you 100 American Meat and a locked in
price the quality is absolutely through
the roof save right now eat the way that
I eat I good ranchers has turned sweet
little Elisa into a ribeye eater it has
it has completely changed my view on
ground beef because it's the greatest
burgers out there this deal is not going
to last forever go to goodranchers.com
use code knowlescana WLS for 25 bucks
off and free ground beef for two years
lock in your price on America's best
meat for two whole years
goodranchers.com use code nulls for over
500 bucks in savings subscribe to good
ranchers American Meat delivered
speaking of dubious narratives
there's a new crisis guys Democrats have
an urgent campaign
they want to reinstate net neutrality
do you remember net neutrality it's been
about six years now I still don't really
know what net neutrality is
all I was told in 2017
When Donald Trump was about to get rid
of net neutrality
was that this was going to destroy the
internet we weren't going to be able to
use the internet as we knew it was going
to be over not only that people were
going to die
this is what they told us if
some executive agency changed some
slight rule about how the isps were
regulated and then what happened they
got rid of net neutrality and
everything was fine actually the only
thing that changed was that internet
speeds increased a little bit but
everything else
it was fun your bill didn't really
change you're not nothing nothing
changed well anyway the Democrats want
to reinstate it 27 Senate Democrats have
written a letter to the chairman of the
FCC Jessica Rosen warsell
urging her to reinstate the title II
regulations on isps known as net
neutrality uh they they want to defend
the free and open internet which Remain
the only the only thing that
risks making the internet no longer free
and open is when the Democrats come in
and censor everything on the internet
otherwise it's pretty free and open but
the Democrats just want to be totally
sure and so they want to reinstate new
neutrality what we can learn from this
is nothing about the internet it's
nothing really about regulation or isps
what we can learn from this
is that the Democrats the libs
never give up they never give up not
even on that Teensy tiniest least
significant things
they are always plowing ahead with their
agenda
conservatives I'm sorry to say we're not
always like that sometimes we are
we've held the line on life on the issue
of abortion even after Roe v Wade in
1973 the conservatives held firm and we
kept pushing pushing pushing then
eventually
we got to overrule
the terrible decision in Roe v Wade that
was great but in a lot of issues we just
Let It Go all marriage yeah that's over
we lost that one oh the structure of the
government the way our constitutional
works oh yeah okay yeah well we lost
that one it's no big deal oh well you
know porn on the ubiquitous porn on the
Internet yeah there's nothing really we
can do sorry we lost that one ah well
blah blah blah the Democrats never think
that way and we should emulate them
we should notice that they just if they
take a loss even if it's the end of the
world catastrophic loss of net
neutrality falling away they just plow
ahead and six years later they remember
this stupid rule from the FCC we need to
do that too you also need to remember to
wear very very fine undergarments which
is why you've got to check out Tommy
John right now go to tommyjohn.com
Knowles it is full you know what that
means cozy nights with the family thanks
to our friends at Tommy John loungewear
for a night in has never been better at
the Perfect Blend of comfort and
breathability their loungewear has a
level of softness that you have never
felt before they're incredibly soft
loungewear is designed to envelop you in
a world of pure luxury when you wear
Tommy John you are so much more
comfortable that you can do everything
better
even their undergarments have dozens of
comfort Innovations breathability
lightweight moisture wicking fabric this
might be I may be wearing Tommy Johns
right now I was at least wearing it
recently and just thinking about how it
is the absolute greatest
undergarment that has ever been made
right now get 20 off your first order
right now
tommyjohn.com Knowles that is 20 off
your first order right now at
tommyjohn.com Knowles C site for details
and feel as comfy and stylish as I do
all the time tommyjohn.com Knowles
speaking of democrat Senators you know
Bob Menendez
is uh in a lot of hot water right now
Bob Menendez was caught with money in
his
house with his coat pockets in every
gold bar is luxury cars the guy is
crooked and they got him dead to rights
some Democrats are calling on him to
resign Sherrod Brown of Ohio says
Senator Menendez has broken the public
trust and should resign from the U.S
Senate he he is the chairman of the
committee on banking Housing and Urban
Affairs John Federman also called on him
to resign or at least some staff member
of his did and New Jersey governor Phil
Murphy called on him to resign these are
all Democrats the alleged facts are so
serious that they compromise the ability
of Senator Menendez to effectively
represent the people of our state
therefore I am calling for his immediate
resignation and even menendez's fellow
New Jersey senator Cory Booker has
called on him to resign uh Cory Booker
has said I don't have his sadly I don't
have his very uh meticulously written
comment here but the the thrust of it
was I love Bob he's a good guy I really
he's he's not the man that's being
portrayed in the Press is not the man
that I know and he's entitled to uh
defense and he's entitled to the
presumption of innocence
but he should resign I just I think he
should probably resign and he did it
very fairly gracefully but he gently
suggested that Menendez resigned and
people are making fun of Booker for this
statement because he was so mealy
mouthed and so everyone knows that
Menendez is extremely corrupt but I
gotta say I actually appreciate Booker's
loyalty I think loyalty is an important
thing in politics Booker might be trying
to ride the fence a little bit here but
I still appreciate that he's not totally
beaten up on the guy nevertheless
Menendez is not going to resign
he's not he's not going to reside he's
completely Shameless he was already
brought up on these corruption charges I
guess he was really investigated by his
colleagues on the corruption charges the
the
Ethics Committee
seem to think that Menendez did some
pretty crooked stuff uh you've heard
these headlines for over a decade now
and he still sticks it out and he still
remains chairman of the Foreign Affairs
committee and he's still peddled U.S
influence shamelessly even after he was
investigated and chastised for it so
he's not going anywhere
the only way that Menendez is going to
resign is if
they offer not to prosecute him and
maybe not to prosecute his wife and
frankly he's probably going to try to
keep his Senate retirement fund
I was talking to some friends here in
Washington DC that's that's
how corrupt this town is and I think
they're right I think they're probably
right that that's what he's waiting for
he has nothing to lose he's not worried
about being shamed he has no shame
so his only chip right now is he's
holding on to the senate seat every day
that he holds on to the senate seat the
more likely it is that a republican will
be able to win that seat in New Jersey
don't forget New Jersey is not just a
completely locked solid Blue State it's
pretty blue but Republicans win there
with some frequency the chrysosons Chris
Christie was a republican governor in
New Jersey not that long ago so it could
happen and Menendez he doesn't care if
some Republican succeeds him he doesn't
really believe in anything other than
the almighty dollar so he's going to
stick this out until he gets guarantees
that he's not going to spend the rest of
his life in a prison cell
and then maybe he will resign and
speaking of playing the hand you're
dealt president Trump
has just tried to blow the whistle on
Pennsylvania rigging the election once
again Pennsylvania which was the most
Brazen in rigging the election in 2020
because they violated their own state
constitution by sending those mail-in
ballots out to everybody unsolicited
at Pennsylvania now is is pushing
automatic voter registration and Trump
says Pennsylvania is at it again the
radical left Governor Josh Shapiro has
just announced a switch to automatic
voter registration a disaster for the
election of Republicans including your
favorite President me this is a totally
unconstitutional act and must be met
harshly by Republican leadership in
Washington and Pennsylvania
uh Pennsylvania Pennsylvania Michigan
Georgia Arizona Wisconsin and others are
far more important than Ada sloppy Chris
lion Mike Pence Nikki Birdbrain Haley
Ron parentheses dead campaign to
sanctimonious and others all right
he's just reusing old nicknames the Ada
thing I don't quite get unless it I
think it refers to ASA Hutchinson and
maybe that Broadway musical and then
sloppy Chris he used he used sloppy for
Steve Bannon lion Mike Pence he
obviously used lion for Ted Cruz lion
Ted l-y-i and Apostrophe a bird brain I
guess is a new one Ron dead campaigned
the sanctimonious those are those are
two nicknames there for the one guy and
but anyway so he's reusing them not not
surprising and he says start suing now
get the lawyers right this time
the Pennsylvania Republican party must
likewise not let this happen it will be
a disaster for our nation which is being
destroyed by these lunatics Marxist
fascists whose only real ability is to
cheat on the elections now you might
dislike Trump's rhetoric there and you
might say look the the primary is not
over yet things could change they don't
seem likely to change but it's not
totally over yet still though
broadly speaking
I think Trump's point is correct
the point that we have got to focus on
making sure that the libs don't rig the
election again we've got to focus on the
nitty-gritty of the election rules the
way that Democrats are changing things
such that they have an advantage and we
have a disadvantage
that's got to be the focus especially
with the polls as they are because the
polls right now are saying Donald Trump
is way up on Biden nationally he's nine
points up on Biden nationally and even
in the key States Donald Trump is doing
very well against Biden and Trump is
very likely to be the the Republican
nominee
so he's doing so well Biden's doing so
poorly okay then how could Trump lose
the election he could lose the election
one because things change in the course
of a year but two because
the surveys are not always indicative of
what's going to happen when people are
counting those ballots without any poll
Watchers and pipes bursting in the
middle of the night
which is why we've got to focus on the
rules and it's very difficult for
conservatives to focus on the rules here
because
conservatives need to figure out a way
to make the politically viable case
against automatic voter registration
it's it sounds like we hate democracy if
we say well I don't want voters to be
automatically registered why not you
don't want more people to vote you want
to suppress the vote you want and and so
it's very difficult to make the case
now I think the case is easy enough
rather I think the argument is easy
enough the argument being that if
someone is not able or inclined to walk
down the street and register to vote
before an election they probably
shouldn't be voting because they're not
responsible people and they're not
paying close enough attention I think
that's simple enough but it sounds kind
of undemocratic so how do we make that
case I think the way we make that case
is just bluntly and honestly
and we appeal to people's uh greater
civic responsibility than the civic
responsibility of their peers
you got to talk to people and say Hey
look
there's a lot of people in this country
who don't care about our form of
government and they don't care about
politics and they're not responsible
citizens and that's fine they can go
about their lives but
they shouldn't they're therefore weigh
in you citizen that I'm talking to right
now at any stage in your life in any
part of the country at any socioeconomic
tier you if you're listening to this
political message right now you're the
kind of person that I do want voting and
so to protect your right to vote to
break to your influence in the country
we need to make sure that people who
would throw their vote away are not
automatically encouraged to do it
because when you're going to throw your
vote away when you don't know anything
about politics and Justice and a form of
government that is when you are most
likely to vote for Democrats
who doesn't love a good Columbus Day
Sale I for one think that Columbus Day
should be not only a national holiday
but an international holiday one of the
most important days of the year some
folks don't even want to celebrate it
though well at Jeremy's raisers we want
you to discover the new world of woke
free shaving get 20 to zero percent off
select Jeremy's razors products and
bundles including the Precision 5
starter kit the founders kit the beard
kit the Skin Care bundle and more be a
Pioneer for a better shave and better
hygiene don't wait make the switch today
get yours at Jeremy's razors
dot com
uh speaking of trump in all of these
polls uh Trump right now is up Five
Points over Biden nationally according
to a a messenger Harris poll this is
going to increase the pressure to get
Donald Trump to get Joe Biden rather out
of the race by the Democrats because we
sometimes think that the Democrats are
so powerful they control all of the
institutions the academy the media the
administrative government the big Tech
the corporation they control all of the
institutions increasingly the military
but they're not omnipotent
they're not God
I think they can still lose elections
they lost in 2016 when we were told that
was going to be impossible
I think that can still happen if their
candidate is sufficiently bad and our
candidate is sufficiently smart I think
we can win
so you're going to see that push and
you're also going to see the push to rig
the vote which is why we gotta we gotta
try to stop that
the liberals do not care about the rules
I don't know if you follow one of the
great accounts on Twitter cat turd
it's an amazing thing about American
politics now that one of the more
popular and insightful commentators is
someone named Kat turd cat turd was just
swatted
swatting is when someone calls in a
report to the police and says you got to
come and bring your guns and come in
blazing because there's a problem at
this address and they put the address of
someone else and then the cops show up
you know guns out and it's a very
dangerous situation here's what happened
this happened live on stream cat's house
has just been swatted someone called and
pretended to be him and said that he had
stabbed someone and had a gun and was
going to kill himself cops are
absolutely everywhere they're all over
cat turd Ranch he is trying to defuse
the situation as we speak I just got
this in from him so no he will not be
rejoining the podcast I'm sorry about
that but oh my gosh keep him and the
puppies in your prayers because this is
how the left operates when you're over
the target they've done it to several
other podcasters I knew it wasn't if it
was when please keep him in your prayers
yes this just happened at the cat turd
Ranch I I really expect this to happen
to all of us we're all going to be
targets of this this game that the left
continues to play
that's it
that's what happens it's not the first
time I'm going on Tim Poole's show
tonight I hope they don't SWAT Tim
they've swatted Tim Poole too what is
swatting
swatting is not just filing a false
police report swatting his attempted
murder what you are doing is you're
saying hey there's a dangerous situation
we want highly trained fighting forces
to show up with guns blazing at this
person's house because we don't like
that person because that person has
political views that we disagree with
this is what they're willing to do we
know they're willing to do it
when I showed up to the University of
Pittsburgh last semester antifa showed
up and threw explosives at the building
okay they mean business they they don't
just want to play around
this is attempted murder and we need to
change the law to reflect that because
this is this has happened to a number of
my friends and the conservatives don't
do it to the libs nor should we but the
libs do it to the conservatives a lot
and this is attempted murder and the
Libs who call this stuff in should be
charged with attempted murder and should
rot Behind Bars what do we do now in
this country we take
74 year old pro-life women who peaceably
demonstrate in front of abortion clinics
and we throw them in prison for the rest
of their lives that's what Joe Biden is
doing right now and he's doing it to
eight pro-life advocates
meanwhile someone tries to kill a
conservative commentator because they
don't like what cat turd is saying about
the 2024 election that person can try to
murder cat turd and that person just
goes off scot-free
the way to stop this kind of behavior
is with a little bit of a heavier hand
the way to exercise that little bit of a
heavier hand is to win elections and
then wield political power effectively
to defend the innocent people and to
punish our enemies who are doing unjust
things and if we're not willing to do
that if all if all conservatives are
willing to do is just dangle the carrot
in front of people conservatives are
pretty good about incentives which are
especially economic incentives so if all
we're willing to do is dangle the carrot
we're not willing to wield the stick
then we're not going to get very far we
also need to punish our enemies when
they are doing things that are unjust
when they're trying to murder us
speaking of crime Wisconsin
has just forced women to share a prison
cell or a prison broadly with an
incestuous tree
[Music]
it's a threat to all of our Liberty this
was the subject of my speech last night
because Liberty contrary to what a lot
of people think is not merely a matter
of choice
choosing between good and bad and to
revolting right and wrong Liberty is is
a matter of willing
and willing is presupposes understanding
and so
this seems a little bit abstract but the
reason that this is an important
distinction is because if Freedom were
merely Choice then God would not be free
because God cannot choose to sin because
God's very being precludes evil
this would be true for all of us if we
are virtuous people and we Tamp down all
of our vices
then we are less free
to choose to do those vices this is true
for anyone who ever has any kind of
habit think of it in the opposite
direction
if you're a heroin addict you've
developed this habit of heroin
you are less free to stop shooting up
heroin
right so it's not so you're obviously
not
a totally free man if you're a heroin
addict contrary to what the Liberals say
because your will has been compromised
and your will is compromised in part
because your intellect is compromised so
God obviously being free is free because
he Wills perfectly and understands
perfectly he's the only he's the only
being who's perfectly free and who wills
and understands perfectly we will be
free only in as much as we align our
wills and our intellects with God this
is the meaning of the phrase in the
Bible
the truth will set you free
Scandal intellectual Darkness lies
pervading Society
compromise all of our Liberty
because they stop us from willing good
and true things
and the society crumbles this is why you
don't want to have a society that is
ordered according to lies because it
screws things up for everybody which
brings me too
Britney Spears
is dancing around her home with knives
with big shark knives and Brittany since
her conservatorship has been lifted
Brittany has posted a lot of odd videos
half naked or naked dancing around
on Tick Tock and doing things that don't
seem particularly helpful to her
she's now denied this so you can see the
video playing around on Tick Tock she's
denied it though
and said I started playing in the
kitchen with knives today don't worry
they're not real knives
Halloween is soon
with three exclamation marks every time
but I look at those knives
they look pretty real they don't look
like plastic knives or anything to me
maybe they're fake maybe they're just
really really good fakes but I don't
know Britney's exhibited a ton of crazy
behavior in recent years and I guess
really for 15 years now
so I have to ask myself
was it really a good idea to free
Britney there's the free Brittany
movement when she was under a
conservatorship and the free Brittany
movement was based on this idea that
Brittany has the right to Liberty
just true we all we all want Liberty
Liberty is a good thing but the reason
the free Brittany movement was wrong is
because the the free Brittany movement
presupposed a definition of Liberty
based on choice not based on perfect
willing and understanding so this is a
very very important distinction if your
will is compromised
if you're a degenerate addict or
something
then you can't be granted this
this kind of political Liberty and we
have programs in our justice system to
limit your political Liberty
and not even to limit your Liberty to
recognize that your Liberty is limited
and so they're going to constrain your
field of operation in politics if you
are ignorant if you if you're something
as defective in your intellect
then your Liberty is going to be limited
this is why we have conservatorships
this is why we have legal Powers of
Attorney this is why we have parental
rights it's because little kids
aren't in control of their will and
aren't particularly educated yet and so
they don't get to vote
until the Democrats have their way and
they lower the voting age to five they
don't get to whatever drive a car they
don't get to participate in Civic life
it seems like a little bit of an
abstract issue well my definition of
Liberty is this and your definition of
Liberty that this this is a crucial
thing
Freedom Liberty is a defining feature
perhaps the defining feature of human
nature but the left and the right in
this country and frankly even there's a
disagreement of this on the on the right
we disagree over what that means and
until we figure out what that means if
we continue to persist in this false
Liberty which is nothing more than
Choice the country is going to continue
to degrade and we're going to be a whole
country of Britney Spears's
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Tas
gb5 pH who says I'm a big lib but this
was a good show well done Michael you
get it right sometimes thank you I love
that comment
I love that comment because
I love it when Libs tune into the show
I've had people write in I actually met
some people last night who said Michael
I was a huge lib and then I started
listening to the show and now I'm a
conservative and that does my heart so
good because I don't want to just preach
to the choir there are some
conservatives in politics in the media
who just want to recite the talking
points to the amen chorus among the
already converted but that's not what I
want to do I want to reach out
to you Libs and I want to pull you over
so that's great I'm glad you liked the
video okay
speaking of things that can kill you
Beyond Britney's kitchen knives
the Wuhan Institute of virology says
that another coronavirus outbreak is
highly likely
and they would know weren't wouldn't
they
study published by scientists at the
Wuhan Institute in July reportedly
circulating widely on Chinese social
media has concluded that as many as 20
species of coronavirus are highly likely
to cause an outbreak among humans
right about on time yeah
yeah that's
because you see the election is in about
13 months so this is right right about
on time the study appeared in emerging
microbes and infections in July the
South China Morning Post noted but it
began making headlines in Chinese
language media as social media users
discovered it and began spreading its
conclusions online what are they saying
they're saying quote this is according
to the study it is almost certain that
there will be future disease emergence
and is highly likely a COV coronavirus
disease again thus the early preparation
for the animal kovies with risk of
spillover is important for future
disease preparedness regarding the
likely animal origin of SARS MERS and
covet 19. I don't want to sound like a
conspiracy theorist I didn't bring my
tinfoil hat with me to Washington DC
you remember right before the outbreak
of kovid there was that big
exercise with scientists and government
officials and ngos where they they just
did a test run of what it would look
like if a coronavirus spread throughout
the world and caused a mass pandemic and
a shutdown of governments and economies
you know and then it just happened
almost immediately thereafter
it would seem reasonable to conclude
from such an exercise that uh
something was likely to happen well I
think that's what we're seeing here
they're telling us what's going to
happen and you can you can take the most
extreme view of it and say they're
planning it and they're intentionally
going to release it and it's going to
it's to shut down the election or you
could just say yeah look they're
the Wuhan Institute of virology is just
like all human institutions is kind of
weak and fallen and when you're dealing
with very dangerous things sometimes
they leak and we're just there it's a
prediction rather than a promise either
way maybe you're somewhere in the middle
between those two poles either way
I think I think covet is going to happen
again are the people willing to go along
with it
I have friends of mine conservative
friends who live through 2020 and 2021
2022 who insist oh Michael
the people will never go along with
covet again
what are you talking about
no Michael them they learn their lesson
you think they learned their lesson no
no they didn't I have liberal friends
who are wearing masks right now already
they're not even mandated yet
even after we were told the masks don't
really work even after we were told that
the vaccines don't really work even
after we were told that the social
distancing was completely arbitrary
they're already doing it again
people's memories are very very short
and people just kind of Follow the
Leader
that's why political power is so
important is we're not all just hyper
individualists who you know form all of
our own conclusions and write long
treatises about about what we think
about every aspect of society if that
were true we wouldn't get out of bed in
the morning
people just basically Follow the Leader
in the established powers and the
established Powers over in China China
and here in the United States and the
fauces and the nihs and the public
health officials in New York and
Lionsgate in California and the Morris
Brown College in Atlanta and Rutgers in
New Jersey they're all just starting to
do covet again
and
people probably will just go along with
it now speaking of
death
uh Rupert Murdoch has stepped down I
meant to get to the story last week I'm
glad that I can get to it right now
Rupert Murdoch is 92 years old he's not
dead he's not dying as far as I can tell
but the very fact that he gave up his
media Empire
makes me think you know the man perhaps
is not long for this world Rupert
Murdoch was chairman of the board of fox
Corporation and news corporation this
guy is the most important media Mogul of
our entire time he has been a rock star
in shaping public opinion for seven
decades
one cannot overstate Rupert Murdoch's
influence his career began in 1952 okay
when he took over running the news which
was a small newspaper in South Australia
that was owned by his father and uh and
he's just
taken over the entire news ever since
now he's 92 he's leaving the company to
his son Lachlan Murdoch and we'll see if
they are able to maintain their
dominance I'm not convinced that they
are actually I think fox has kind of
slipped in recent years many of you
think that too A lot of people have
tuned out in part because fox has moved
to the left in part because people are
just cutting cable
the reason the Murdoch story matters is
because
the media landscape is changing
dramatically
and media changes don't just happen
gradually
they happen pretty suddenly you've got
the age of radio then you got the age of
TV doesn't mean that radio goes away but
it loses its Primacy in terms of shaping
public opinion at the age of TV then you
got the age of the internet then you've
got the age of streaming internet and as
these things have shifted
and you've got the age of Twitter which
is where most people get their news now
anyway as these things have shifted
people just totally turn away I have
I appear on cable news with some
frequency
I have never personally subscribed to
cable
ever
my parents had cable when I was a kid
some friends have had K I have never in
my whole life
and I'm on cable and I don't young
people just don't
watch that stuff
and the reason that matters is not just
because of how people are entertained
but because especially in a democracy
the media shapes the whole political
order
this is why it was so crucial that Elon
Musk by X formerly known as Twitter
whoever controls the media whoever
controls the language is going to
control
politics and
Rupert Murdoch did a good job of giving
conservatives a little bit of a shot to
maybe fight against the a Total
Domination in the media by the libs a
little tiny sliver but now we're in a
totally new landscape and
the the shifts in media are going to
predict shifts in the political order so
what is it going to look like
post Rupert we've got a 70-year run here
what happens now the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
I'm here in my hotel room in Washington
DC I would be chatting with you if
you want to join you got to go to
diy.com use code Knowles for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]